JAMES CLEWETT: I mean, the
important point is that the
internet is full.
That's the tabloid headline.
The internet is full.
There's now so many machines
attached to the internet that
there is no way that
they can all have
their own unique address.
Not the way we're currently
addressing them.
All right.
Well, the number is
4,294,967,296.
A packet is what happens to the
information that you're
trying to send on
the internet.
Your computer breaks it down
into bit-sized chunks, and it
sends it off bundled up.
It's like putting it
in an envelope.
And on the front of the
envelope, it writes this
unique number, which is the IP
address, and sends it off
across the internet.
And then every router, every
switch that it encounters as
it travels down the internet,
looks at the number on the
front and goes, ah, I know
where to send that.
And it weaves its way, not
in any unique manner--
actually, it's a very random
process-- but it weaves its
way through the internet routers
and eventually finds
your machine.
So essentially, every machine
is addressed by a unique
number, because computers
cannot, they don't have
written addresses.
And they're all designed in
such a way that they are
stored in a 32-bit number.
Now what that basically means is
that you've got 32 lines of
1 or 0, the binary value.
And that means that there must
be some limit to how big a
value you can store.
And that value-- well, if you
remember, we did in the
Pac-Man video the biggest value
you can store in an
8-bit number.
OK, well, that's 2
to the power 8.
The biggest value you can store
in a 32-bit number is 2
to the power 32.
So I mean, that's the headline
The internet is full.
And what I mean by that is that
on the 3rd of February
last year, the authority that
hands out numbers to the
agencies that then manage who
gets what address handed out
their last value.
So there are no more.
So if you're now a new company,
and you want to set
up a business and have your own
website and have your own
address for people to come and
see you, there's none left.
Simple as that.
It's full.
Well, I mean, there's various
things that are being done to
mitigate the problem.
They're going back through the
addresses that they've handed
out in the past, and they're
looking to see if they're
being used.
And if they're not being used,
then they're harvesting them
to hand them out again.
It's not really going to solve
the problem for very long.
So we need to take a wholly
new approach, and that
approach is to throw away the
32-bit solution-- as always
with computers.
You throw away the small ones.
Remember when we used to have
8-bit computers, and we could
count up to 256, and
that was fine?
But eventually, we wanted to
count to more than 256.
So we threw those away, and
we got new computers.
And they could count
up to 65,536.
And then we wanted to count to
bigger numbers than that, so
we threw those ones away, too,
and we brought in 32-bit
computers, which is what most of
our viewers will be using.
And 32-bit computers can count
up to 4 billion, which is
quite a big number.
But even that is beginning
to reach its limit.
So now we're starting to build
computers that can count up to
2 to the 64.
And I've just realized that
you're now going to ask me
what that number is,
and I don't know.
So down here we've got the
32-bit computers that we're
now throwing away in
our laboratory,
because we've moved on.
We're on to 64-bit computing
now, so we can count to really
big numbers.
Around your home, there's an
awful lot of things connected
to the internet--
primarily your phone and your
computer, at the moment, or
your tablet computer.
And then there's crazy people
who want to connect your
washing machine and
your fridge and
your house's heating.
There's all sorts of ideas about
things you could connect
to the internet.
And every one of those
needs to be addressed
in some unique way.
Because if it's not got a unique
address, then that
introduces confusion.
If two things have got the same
address, and I want to
talk to them, if I'm
a computer--
which, you know, some
people think--
and I want to send information,
then if two
things have got the same
address, I don't know which
one of those two I'm trying
to communicate with.
Most businesses, like the
University of Nottingham,
where we are, have dynamic
allocation of addresses.
So you switch your machine on,
and some server somewhere
says, ah, yes, you'll
need an address,
and hands it an address.
And that's only valid for
while it's switched on.
But of course, the server can
only hand out a certain amount
of addresses.
It's only got maybe
65,000 addresses
that it can hand out.
Probably fewer than that.
Obviously, at some point,
it runs out.
And that tends to be
what's happening.
The biggest problem that we're
seeing at the moment is just
dynamic allocation of IP
addresses, a thing called
DHTP, failing because companies
are running out of
their own IP addresses.
And so they have to
go back for more.
BRADY: So for example, the
university here can only hand
out from a finite number
of addresses
that it already owns?
JAMES CLEWETT: That's right.
It has to request addresses
from a regional authority.
And the regional authority here
covers Europe and about
half of Asia, Russia,
and the Middle East.
And then there are regional
authorities for Oceania and
China and Africa and Latin
America and North America.
And the regional authorities
request addresses from an
international authority.
And if you trace it all back,
eventually this is all funded
by the US Defense Department,
which is a little bit sad.
No, I like the US Defense
Department.
They're good people.
And, I-- oh dear.
They've handed out the last
of their IP addresses.
They've handed out this many to
the regional authorities.
The regional authorities
are expected to run out
sometime this year.
Problem.
The solution to this problem is
that we are going to change
from IP version 4, which has
been around since I think
about 1981, sometime around
then, and we're going to
change to IP version 6.
I don't know what happened
to IP version 5.
Now IP version 6 is based
on 128-bit number.
Now 128 bits, just to put that
in some sort of perspective,
what that means is that every
person can have billions upon
billions upon billions
of devices each.
So we're not going to run out
of space any time soon
with IP version 6.
The problem now is
a human problem.
There's a whole bunch of
companies out there who are
running the routers and the
switches around the internet,
which are passing information
from one machine to another
machine, that need to upgrade
their routers to IPv6.
And they're not doing it.
There's a very, very slow
uptake, and purely for
economic reasons, I presume.
It's an effort.
And you've got to pay somebody
to make that effort.
And so it's just not
getting done.
The adoption's appalling.
The 8th of June, 2011 and the
6th of June, this year, 2012,
were test days for IP version
6, where there was a certain
amount of uptake.
Companies were encouraged to
switch on their IPv6 and
provide their material
through IPv6.
And it all went smoothly.
Nobody noticed.
Brilliant.
So we're getting there,
slowly but surely.
BRADY: The web address
of Numberphile is
www.numberphile.com.
JAMES CLEWETT: Right.
BRADY: What's going on there?
JAMES CLEWETT: That's
not its web address.
That's some human-readable
form.
So as well as providing you
with a unique number, what
your internet service provider
is doing is using a thing
called domain names.
It has a table which ties
that domain name
to the unique number.
Because if we were all having
to wander around remembering
the unique 32-bit number for all
of our favorite websites,
whether that is Sixty Symbols
or Numberphile
or Test Tube, or--
you choose which one
you like the most.
We'd forget them, right?
Because that's too many.
So at some point-- and I don't
know when-- somebody had the
bright idea of just tying a
meaningful name to these
things, and that's what
you're remembering.